on pourrait croire que tous les italiens
se retrouve pour un mariage
et francesco le premier il a mis son
plus beau costume et il sourit à pleines
dents
mais en fait francesco vient célébrer si
on peut dire les 35 ans d'une
catastrophe baptisé massacre douce tic à
une chaleur étouffante et des souvenirs
81 morts dans le crash d'un avion de
ligne près de l'île d'ustica au nord de
la sicile en 1981 moustique a jamais
entendu parler en france mais en italie
c'est un drame national
et francesco ne sourit plus pour tous
ceux qui n'ont pas connu la tragédie de
la perte
les plus jeunes
pardonnez moi pardonnez moi chaque année
la même émotion
trente cinq ans après le deuil n'est
toujours pas fait
francesco et les autres familles ne sont
pas en paix avec leurs morts cela me
fait penser aux boxeurs qui prend des
coups francs dès qu'on prend des coups
mais nous aussi nous prenons des coûts
et des gifles mais nous sommes toujours
debout
on continuera à avancer on ne s'arrêtera
pas
madame ans obama
ces familles italiennes frappé de plein
fouet à la veille de l'été 1981
continuent de se battre pour connaître
une vérité occulté car oui stick à reste
l'une des dernière tragédie aérienne non
élucidées 27 juin 1981
quelque part en méditerranée un avion de
ligne italien disparaît des radars ce
petit dc-9 d'itavia qui assurait la
liaison bologne palerme avec
quatre-vingt-une personnes à bord dont
15 enfants
[Musique]
en enquêtant nous avons découvert une
vérité dérangeante
le petit dc-9 se serait retrouvé au
milieu d'un combat aérien
nous avions militaires parce qu'ils vont
vite ils vont très vite la plus grande
probabilité ekwalla que c'est celle
d'amis un missile mais qu'il aurait tiré
pratiquement pas d'indiça par une
accusation à peine croyable
lancé en 2007 par l'ancien président de
la république italienne en personne
c'étaient les français qui ont fait
décoller un chasseur du porte avions
clemenceau de wallin un chasseur qui
avait lancé un missile us mme et
pourtant l'état français en 35 ans ne
s'est jamais exprimé sur ustica
[Musique]
sur la france
on n'a jamais fait donc être sérieuse
peut-être que l'anc est la plus précise
c'est celle que vous êtes en train de
faire
alors l'armée de l'air française
auraient-elles commis une terrible
bavure dans le ciel italien en juin 1981
enquête
pour démarrer notre investigation
direction les archives d'état italiennes
à rome depuis deux ans tout ce qui
concerne ustica a été ouvert au public
c'est là que nous retrouvons francesco
ces journées il les passe ici en quête
d'un détail qui pourrait expliquer le
drame
en 1981 francesco ici à gauche sur la
photo avait 12 ans c'est lui qui devait
monter dans l'avion avec sa grande soeur
mais son petit frère de 10 ans que l'on
voit à droite rêve de prendre l'avion et
il insiste pour prendre sa place
juste avant l'embarquement de racheter à
contenir on devait partir ma soeur et
moi est retourné à palerme
mon frère dit papa je voudrais parti en
avion mon père contrarier dit non c'est
francesco qui part mais mon petit frère
avait un caractère très vif
il a insisté et insisté et finalement il
a réussi à convaincre mon père de le
laisser partir à ma place felice
il était heureux tellement heureux de
pouvoir voler pour la première fois et
disons qu est ce que ça fait 35 ans
qu'il continue à voler il n'a jamais
atterri son rêve est réalisé à jamais
[Musique]
qui a tué le petit frère et la grande
soeur de francesco
mister
pour honorer leurs morts les familles
n'ont que ce mémorial à bologne
80 une ampoule symbolisant les victimes
au dessus de l'avion recomposée avec les
débris retrouvés au début des années
1990 au fond de la méditerranée
chaque année francesco fait le
déplacement
et à chaque fois la même image du
revient chaque fois que je viens ici je
me dis que derrière tel ou tel hublot
mon frère regarder la mer ainsi à côté
de ma soeur c'est la dernière chose qui
me relief mais la douleur vient d'abord
et avant tout d'un sentiment que toutes
les familles partagent l'impression que
les autorités ne leur ont jamais dit la
vérité
ils sont morts dans un acte de guerre
dont on ne connaît pas les responsables
et pour nous c'est comme si cet avion
continuer à voler le jour on aura tous
les éléments de la vérité alors pour
nous cet avion aura enfin atterri et
nous pourrons définitivement enterré nos
proches
cette vérité sur le crash du 27 juin
1981 nous avons tenté de l'établir
ce soir là le dc-9 d'école de bologne à
20h08 le temps éclair le ciel dégagé
ce sont des conditions idéales les à
20h59 de façon inexpliquée l'avion
disparaît brutalement des écrans radar
près de l'île d'ustica aériennes de la
nuit dernière n'a pas l'air demeure
inexplicable toutes les conditions de
vol était normal y compris les liaisons
radio jusqu'au moment de la
désintégration de l'appareil à une
altitude qui restent déterminés car on
va d'interrogation en interrogation
comment le pilote n'a pas pu en quelques
secondes
alertés les stations radios et rend
également ses sept avions révisé il ya
tout juste une semaine
subitement pour tenter de comprendre
nous allons commencer par fouiller dans
les archives italienne ouverte au public
depuis que les images archives de rome
et avec la tout ça c'est rustique a
uniquement un sticker l'aéronautique et
tous les dossiers qui nous occupe donc
là on a plusieurs millions de pages de
documents qui ont été déclassifiés en
des millions de documents ouverts au
public
mais problème la plupart sont anodins de
simples éléments de contexte des
rapports techniques des courriers des
articles de presse bizarrement les
documents les plus intéressants sont pas
là de toute façon
dans cette affaire une soi-disant piste
terroriste a longtemps été véhiculées
par la presse
quarante huit heures après le drame un
grand quotidien italien raconte qu'un
interlocuteur anonyme a appelé le
journal il s'est présenté comme membre
d'une organisation néo fasciste et a
évoqué un attentat
une bombe aurait explosé dans les
toilettes de l'appareil
elle aurait été transportée par cet
homme un certain marco à faty gâteau
activiste néo fasciste bien connue des
services italiens seraient morts dans le
crash
problème si la fatigue gâteau existe
bien il n'a jamais pris ce vol et encore
moins transporter une bombe ce jour là
si nous pouvons l'affirmer c'est parce
que nous l'avons retrouvé en pleine
forme
mais si la fatigue et ça c'est un
article qui montre qu'en 1999
oui en fait je touche quoi
cet appel anonyme et de faisait signe
que moi j'étais dans l'avion avec des
explosifs
pas pour faire sauter l'avion mais
c'était une attaque avait dû être commis
aussi six mois je voyageais dans l'avion
avec des explosifs
en découvrant l'article du corriere
della serra 48 heures après le crash à
faty gâteau comprend qu'il s'agit d'une
machination
et quand vous découvrez la presse it
rien j'appelle dany médias la famille
c'était la même chose
d'abord italienne a parlé d'un moment
elle est tranquillement je suis vivant
voilà touchés étaient prêts j'appelle
aussi les commissariats dès ma ville
qu'est ce que je vais compris qu'il y
avait quelque chose qu'ils savaient pas
comment ça se fait qu'il y avait mon nom
sous cette affaire je pense que
quelqu'un a eu l'idée de me halimi ne
veux pas ça par l'avion marco à faty
gâteau va intenter un procès pour
calomnie et ils découvrent que la fausse
piste terroriste ayman des services
secrets italiens le sismi dirigé à
l'époque par cet homme le général sont
tous vitaux aujourd'hui il est décédé
mais son adjoint francesco patience à
est toujours en vie après des dizaines
de demandes nous finissons par le
joindre au téléphone
et là surprise il continue à s'accrocher
à l'hypothèse de la bombe tout en
changeant de version cette fois ce
serait les libyens détail intéressant ce
qui lui aurait raconté cela ce sont les
services secrets français messieurs
passionne ça pourquoi est-ce que vous
pensez que c'était une bombe là bas
c'est la presse que les français m'ont
dit ce sont les français qui le dandy
probablement 7 est kadhafi
malgré ces invraisemblances la piste
terroriste véhiculée par les services
français restent aujourd'hui encore la
version officielle la bombe aurait
explosé dans les toilettes de l'avion
mais là encore l'association des
familles de victimes a le sentiment de
se faire intoxiquer une bombe mais où ça
il disait dans les toilettes
vous connaissez les avions nous les
connaissons tous sa pt
on sait que les toilettes fonds 1 m sur
40 ou 60 cm il la bandit le lavabo a été
repêché au fond de la mer par intact et
impeach ils l'attaquent et la cuvette
des toilettes est entière
bin abi elle existe mais elle a été
repêchée à latché existe et stats et ps4
pour en avoir le coeur net nous allons
fouiller dans ce lieu en principe
inaccessible les archives judiciaires
italiennes toute la mémoire des procès
de la péninsule
des millions de documents de scellés
[Musique]
ustica ce sont quelques dizaine de
classeurs jauni
c'est là que nous allons retrouver deux
photos fondamentale
les lunette de toilettes du dc9
repêchées au fond de la méditerranée
elles sont bien intact la preuve
qu'aucune bombe n'a explosé dans les wc
car le dc-9 ne comportait qu'une seule
zone de toilettes à l'arrière qui aurait
forcément été dévasté par l'explosion
l'hypothèse de la piste terroriste
véhiculée depuis le début par les
services secrets et donc bidon
d'ailleurs sur la carcasse la zone des
toilettes est la moins touchée
tandis que l'avant en revanche et en
mille morceaux
[Musique]
la piste terroriste est donc une fausse
piste
mais pourquoi les services
français et italiens aurait-il fabriquer
un tel écran de fumée
peut-être parce que dès le début une
autre piste avait émergé une piste très
éloigné de l'hypothèse terroriste
une piste qui met en cause des états
ce journaliste vit depuis trente cinq
ans avec les fantômes moustiques à en
1981 c'était un jeune reporter au
corriere della serra le soir du crash
alors que personne n'est encore au
courant il reçoit un appel qui va le
marquer à jamais un coût et demande à ce
qu à ce moment le téléphone a sonné
aidez-le à hong kong c'était un
contrôleur aérien de l'aéroport
militaire de rome ciampino de ciampino
kemi qui me disait qu'un crash avait eu
lieu à dos nintcheu d'intérêt je ne
savais rien là dessus et il m'a dit eh
bien des torts mais attention ne te fais
pas avoir l'avion a été abattu par un
missile ou et la matinale et 7 et a fini
il a terminé son service à sept heures
du matin puis il est venu chez moi bien
il m'a raconté que cette nuit là il
avait vu des avions militaires et melita
allait presque certainement des
américains et qu'il sentait que l'avion
avait été abattu par un missile par
accident pour une autre raison il ne
savait pas mais il avait été abattu par
un missile ayant comme chat à la volée
sous costa hypogées commencé à
travailler sur cette hypothèse et je me
suis aperçu dès le début pendant parlant
avec des pilotes des copilotes des
professionnels du monde de
l'aéronautique
après tout le monde avait la même
impression que tout y avait main au
costa cen sad sony précise et fort ses
voiles koné pour certains c'était plus
qu'une impression on est déjà à manquer
donc on peut dire que ce qui s'est passé
était déjà connu par beaucoup de monde
dans les heures qui ont suivi l'accident
festival a déjà coaché des morceaux
si c'est un missile tous ceux qui
étaient derrière radars ce soir là ont
pu voir ce qui se passait
le problème c'est qu'en italie dans les
années 1980 une vingtaine de témoins
potentiels militaire ou civil a eu
tendance à mourir prématurément accident
crise cardiaque suicide des décès
suspect d'après la justice italienne
tous avaient eu affaire à ostie qu'à un
moment ou à un autre
parmi ces témoins décédé le sergent
alberto des tories le soir du crash il
était devant son radar
[Musique]
suite au drame le sergent serait rentré
chez lui à grosseto en prononçant une
phrase cruciale
on a frôlé la guerre mondiale muré dans
le silence depuis 35 ans ces enfants
acceptent de nous recevoir et même de
nous faire entrer chez leur maman elle
n'a jamais parlé à aucun journaliste
[Musique]
ce sont les seules photos de lui avec
ses collègues il n'y en a pas d'autre il
était fier de son travail il l'appelait
ma mère l'armée de l'air voilà quel
point ils y croyaient ils y croyaient
dur comme fer
il est entré à l'armée à 18 ans il a
quitté la maison il a tout de suite
commencé c'était toute sa vie il était
tellement doué qu'une fois un de ses
supérieurs lui a dit un tel veto oui je
ne comprends pas quand tu es là au radar
tout fonctionne toujours bien il
faudrait m'expliquer ça mais on joue en
1981 le crash douce ti-cats va
traumatiser alberto
dans les mois qui suivent il devient
dépressif paranoïaque il s'enferme dans
le secret sa femme aussi est restée
secrète pendant 35 ans elle n'a jamais
parlé parce qu'elle a peur
jamin en main bien qu'elle soit avec
ligne après une valse hésitation elle va
nous confirmer que le soir du drame
son mari avait bien parlé de guerre
mondiale évité de justesse
c'est à ma soeur qui l'a dit il ne ment
pas il m'a fait comprendre qu'il y avait
eu un gros bordel mais que c'était leur
affaire à eux
voilà ce qu'il m'a dit en 1987
alberto des tories à la conviction
d'être suivi espionner en permanence par
des italiens mais aussi par des français
et un jour juste avant sa mort
il est même persuadé d'avoir été placée
sur écoute ils voulaient qu'elle
démontre le téléphone et lui disait
goethe on ne parle pas et elle lui
disait albert toriques outre reste
tranquille et lui non non on ne parlera
qu'à mon retour
et entrant il ya 10 à je suis enfin chez
moi il m'a embrassée et anneaux facto la
moustiquaire et puis ils ont fait
l'amour voilà excusera mais vivent à la
rue
il m'a dit prépare toi car la tuer forte
je lui ai dit je serai forte mais là je
n'en peux plus
[Applaudissements]
les radios des raisons d'état ils ont
tué 80 une personne il ya d'autres
victimes
nous aussi nous sommes des victimes ils
nous l'ont massacré
ils y ont tous fait remonter les deux
enfants vont nous emmener près de la
rivière où leur père a été retrouvé
pendu le 31 mars 1987
sept ans après le crash dans leur
souffrance ils sont persuadés qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'un vrai suicide
même s'ils n'ont pas de preuve formelle
et pour cause il n'y a jamais eu
d'autopsié
alberto des tories a été retrouvé pendu
à un arbre
face à cette rivière détail symbolique
il portait un sweat-shirt de l'armée
française peut-être un message sur la
tragédie douce ti-cats qui l'obsédait
littéralement à son poste il était
impossible de ne pas voir ce qui se
passait non parce qu'il voyait les
signaux sur l'écran c'était un témoin
oculaire
il y avait les numéros de code des
avions il en aurait jamais parlé avec
nous jamais parce que il était
traumatisé il avait peur
[Musique]
non il était obsédé et constater cette
torture psychologique elle c'est terminé
ici
alberto des tories est mort avec la
conviction que le 27 juin 1981 on avait
frôlé la troisième guerre mondiale
et pourtant d'après les autorités
italiennes ce soir là il n'y avait pas
un seul avion militaire dans le ciel
autour du dc9 comment expliquer ce
paradoxe
[Musique]
e
en 1990 un nouveau magistrat hérite de
la faire il va passer presque dix ans de
sa vie
pour accoucher de ce gigantesque dossier
cinq mille cinq cents pages un mètre de
hauteur et son enquête marque un
tournant car il réussit enfin à
retrouver des données radar cachée
jusqu'ici par les autorités
et là surprise quelle est la vérité
aujourd'hui sur ces données radar les
données radar nous disent que cette nuit
là contrairement à ce qui nous a été dit
pendant des années alors nous allons
envie qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres
avions près de notre dc-9 les données
ont en fait révélé un ciel plein d'avion
et même des avions engagés dans des
exercices
[Musique]
donc voilà le premier grand mensonge
au début on a cru ce que les services et
l'armée de l'air nous disait qu tôt si à
des services et puis on a étudié les
techniques des radars en détails et on a
pu voir les choses différemment
c'est à dire qu'à ce moment là il y
avait un exercice militaire au milieu de
la méditerranée et ses vols croisé la
trajectoire de notre avis on a vu des
avions qui ont été décrits comme
français et chaîne dévalant qui volaient
parallèlement au dc 9 nova tunes g et
valence puis qu'il rejoignait il lui
couper la route
c'était facile pour eux grâce à la
vitesse supérieure des avions militaires
l'état
des avions militaires sur la trajectoire
du dc9 cette découverte du juge prieuré
et recoupée par un rapport confidentiel
de l'otan que nous nous sommes procurés
le jour du drame il y avait bien un
exercice militaire secret en
méditerranée l'otan est peu bavarde mais
elle fournit tout de même la liste des
avions dans la zone
il y en avait des dizaines certains
identifier d'autres accompagnés de la
mention inconnu une façon de cacher leur
nationalité mais le juge priori va
surtout finir par se procurer de
nouvelles données radar qui n'avait pas
été détruite par les services secrets
italiens celle de la base militaire de
potenza piceno ces données vont être
confiée à des experts dirigés par cet
homme
ils vont pouvoir à partir de millions de
chiffre reconstituer les dernières
minutes du dc9 sur une carte
que sont ces données ita ce sont les
listings qui contiennent les
informations radar du centre militaire
de poté machine à danser 30 colonnes
sont reportés toutes les informations
qui servent à la défense aérienne et pas
un contrôle de vol toutes les
informations qui permettent de dire
qu'elle est l'avion en vol
et quel est son comportement un travail
de fourmi pendant des mois les experts
italiens transforme ces chiffres en kart
et lorsqu'elle finit par se dessiner ils
ne sont pas déçus
[Musique]
alors la peau et sur cette carte est
représentée la dernière minute de vol du
dc9 éminente au niveau landel déchaînant
20h59
il se trouve est ici l'accident a lieu
ici on le voit car ici la trajectoire ne
continue plus matière à nouveau mais il
ya ce nuage déco radars qui correspond
aux débris de l'avion mais l'avion n'est
pas seul il n'est pas seul comment on
peut le voir ici on se rend compte que
l'avion tel qu'il est vu par le radar
ont fait des écarts si elle en réalité
il y à un avion qui est en dessous du
dc9 ou alors qui est proche de lui et le
radar voit parfois le dc-9 et parfois
l'autre avion et ça donne un signal qui
fait les écarts cash flow le petit écho
radar qui zigzague permet de comprendre
que sous le dc-9 se trouve au moins un
autre appareil peut-être deux appareils
non identifié qui se protège des radars
en se cachant sous le dc-9
[Musique]
et puis les experts voient apparaître
deux autres avions beaucoup plus rapide
qui arrive du nord ouest
ce qui est très important
ce sont ces deux points ce sont deux
points qui représente une trajectoire
celle d'avions en vol
nous avions militaires parce qu'ils vont
vivre vraiment très vite et ils n'ont
rien à voir avec le dc-9 nous pensons
que ces deux points signale des avions
qui d'une façon ou d'une autre sont la
cause de l'accident chef et comme entre
eux et le dc-9 il ya une distance de 8
ou 9 km là seules causes possibles de
l'accident est ce un missile les deux
avions de chasse était à bonne distance
pour tirer des missiles
le plus vraisemblable est donc que ce
sont deux chasseurs qui ont abattu le
dc-9 aurait-il ensuite engager un combat
aérien avec les appareils caché en
dessous
[Musique]
à ce stade de notre enquête
un nouvel élément vient accréditer cette
hypothèse trois semaines après le crash
l'armée italienne localise sur la
montagne de sila en calabre
l'épave d'un avion de chasse libyen un
mig la version officielle par et dans la
presse
le pilote aurait fait une crise
cardiaque pendant un vol de routine et
l'avion se serait écrasé par hasard donc
trois semaines après ustica le 18
juillet officiellement c'est donc un
accident qui n'a rien à voir avec le
crash du dc9 pourtant parmi les
militaires envoyés pour récupérer la
carcasse du mig
il y à ce sous-officier aujourd'hui à la
retraite et tout de suite
de nombreux détails le frappe ce sont
mes mémoires
c'est vraiment important
vraiment très important la vérité sur le
pilote est sûre le mig et c'est
mathématique et que le mig n'est pas
tombé le 18 juillet mais avant cette
date
un déchet vert parce que le 18 juillet
le corps du pilote était plus très fier
ou très fins et l'odeur qui en émanait
était insupportable
l'avion était là et moi j'ai marché
jusqu'à la queue de l'avion et j'ai vu
comme ça doit chaîne 2 cm et à côté
peut-être qu'il y en avait d'autres je
n'ai pas fait attention après caen mais
colonel est arrivé je les amener à
l'hôtel et sur le trajet je lui ai
demandé
colonel on a tiré sur l'avion il a été
abattu
il n'a pas répondu à ma question il a
dit en baissant la fenêtre de la voiture
mais qui sait d'où venait ce [ __ ]
d'avion des trou dans la carlingue du
mig libyen nous allons vérifier dans les
archives judiciaires et nous retrouvons
des photos jamais publié de ce fameux
mig notre sous-officier n'avait pas
menti
on voit clairement des impacts dans la
carlingue
donc ça ne peut pas être un simple
accident et le corps du pilote et est
effectivement putréfiés il n'est pas
mort le 18 juillet mais sans doute
plusieurs jours avant un peu plus loin
on apprend qu'il s'agissait du capitaine
ezzeddine rahil un pilote de l'armée de
l'air libyenne
[Musique]
le film des événements devient plus
clair les deux mystérieux chasseur
aurait abattu le dc-9 puis il aurait
poursuivi l'un des mig libyen au dessus
de la calabre et l'aurait abattu à son
tour tout est cohérent avec les
trajectoires sur les cartes et avec les
impacts dans la carlingue du mig
pour en avoir le coeur net en 1995 le
juge priori décide de convoquer un
militaire qui était en poste le 18
juillet 1981 un radariste de la base
militaire de 30 si c'est bien ce jour-là
que le mig s'est écrasé il en a
forcément été informés manque de chance
quelques jours avant le rendez vous chez
le juge
on apprend que ce radariste aussi est
décédé les autorités expliquent qu'il se
serait pendu à une poignée de porte
il s'appelait franco parisy pour la
justice italienne
il est alors le 12e témoin important a
décédé de façon suspecte
en quinze ans
mais de quelle nationalité et et les
chasseurs qui ont tiré
[Musique]
dans les années 90 un peu par hasard
les soupçons du juge priori vont se
porter sur la france car le juge demande
les données radar de la base militaire
de solenzara en corse
elle est idéalement situé elle a
forcément vu passer l'avion solenzara
est une des plus grosses bases aériennes
françaises
elle peut accueillir jusqu'à 40 avions
de chasse c'est un point stratégique en
méditerranée le juge d'instruction a
demandé aux français s'ils avaient vu
quelque chose
il savait que la france avait une base
militaire opérationnelle à solenzara en
corse sa question était avez vous
enregistré quelque chose avec votre
radar la france a répondu non la base a
fermé à 17h si la base est fermé à 17h
cela signifie que quatre heures avant le
crash il n'y a aucun radar opérationnel
et aucun avion n'a pu décoller mais
cette version officielle va vite être
démentie nous avons ensuite après que
des témoins très crédible le soir du
drame n'ont pas réussi à s'endormir
parce qu'ils étaient dans un hôtel
proche de la base militaire et ils n'ont
pas pu dormir jusque très tard parce
qu'il y avait de nombreux décollage et
atterrissage sur la base qui était en
fait active nous avons localisé l'un de
ces témoins clés
ce n'est pas n'importe qui un général
des carabiniers que nous retrouvons chez
lui à gênes
nicolau bozzo est aujourd'hui retraité
le soir du crash il était en vacances à
solenzara
parce que son frère aimait les avions
militaires il passait son temps à les
photographier et ce 27 juin 1981 jour du
crash du stick à a été un square très
particulier nous nous sommes couchés
puis ça a commencé un ouragan un enfer
des bruits très forts d'avion qui venait
et repartez
et au petit matin encore pire il ya eu
un trafic énorme
combien d'avions vous pensez quelques
dizaines et même plus un cas des 40 ou
50 avions d'être une cointre et le
général bozo n'est pas seul à se
rappeler cette nuit agitée
sa femme aussi a une mémoire précise des
événements alors ce ce bruit dans la
nuit oui le bruit il y avait des avions
qui allez venez on était proche de
l'aéroport
on s'est dit c'est un mauvais hôtel il
va falloir changer voilà mais finalement
ça n'était que 7 milles 1 et c'était
moins italiens ne sont pas les seuls à
dynamiter la version officielle de paris
en 2014 une vingtaine d'anciens
militaires français de solenzara ont
reconnu devant la justice italienne que
le soir du drame
la base était bien en activité la france
a donc menti à propos de sa base en
corse
de nombreux avions décoller ce soir là
et potentiellement ils pouvaient abattre
le dc-9 italien
[Musique]
au fil du temps la responsabilité
française se précise
l'ancien président de la république
italienne qui dirigeait le gouvernement
au moment du stick à jette un pavé dans
la mare et il pointe du doigt un
porte-avions français en méditerranée sa
sortie télévisée en 2007 est un coup de
tonnerre
j'étais les français qui ont fait
décoller un chasseur du porte avions
clemenceau elle doit lui un chasseur qui
avait lancé un missile ou aux mousses ou
l'année suivante en 2008 cossiga
confirme ses accusations devant la
justice italienne
d'après lui les français étaient
informés que le colonel kaddafi
emprunterait un couloir aérien italien
et il voulait abattre le leader libyen
[Musique]
quand j'étais président de la république
et giuliano amato président du conseil
il m'a fait part d'une information
transmise par l'amiral martini chef des
services secrets
[Musique]
un avion de la marine française avait
décollé d'un porte-avions au large de la
corse du sud
ils avaient pour mission d'abattre un
avion qui transportait le colonel
kadhafi
[Musique]
pourtant à cette époque la france ne
réagit pas à ces accusations
[Musique]
si l'ancien président du conseil qui est
en exercice au moment de la tragédie le
dis c'est qu'il a des éléments
importants pour le dire ça n'est pas un
coup de folie il s'est pas dit d'un seul
coup tiens je vais inventer une
responsabilité française
on imagine cossiga des taux de seagate
dit avoir eu ces informations par les
services italiens chez dan il faut dire
que la france à chaque fois qu'on lui a
demandé quelque chose au kolkhoze n'a
jamais répondu de façon juste et parfois
elle dit des mensonges et aux délais
budget et queen's donc disons qu'il
existe un soupçon sur la france pour ne
pas avoir répondu aux questions des
magistrats et que c'est un soupçon
concret sur ce point nous allons tenter
de vérifier s'il y avait bien un
porte-avions français en méditerranée le
jour de la tragédie dostie cas
depuis 35 ans la france affirme que non
les deux porte avions de la marine
nationale le foch et le clemenceau
aurait été en rade à toulon ce 27 juin
1981 sauf que nous avons la preuve que
là encore la france a menti il a fallu
la chercher longtemps appelée des
anciens marins pour finir par trouver ce
livre autorisé par l'armée il relate
l'épopée du foch
car francesco cossiga a fait une
confusion ce n'est pas le clemenceau qui
était en mer le 27 juin 1981 c'était le
foch
on signale même avec une précision toute
militaire 11000 appontages entre 1964 et
le 27 juin 1981 justement le jour du
drame du stick à une phrase qui démontre
que ce jour là le porte-avions était
bien en mer et que des avions ont
décollé
entre la base de solenzara et le porte
avions foch
la france a donc pu être à l'origine de
l'attaqué contre les mig libyen caché
sous le dc-9
mais la france at elle a battu le dc-9
[Musique]
un homme pourrait évidemment répondre le
président de la république de l'époque
et chef des armées
valéry giscard d'estaing mais nos
demandes d'interview vont se heurter à
un mur
monsieur giscard d'estaing m'a chargé de
vous remercier pour votre proposition
mais de vous dire qu'il regrettait de ne
pouvoir vous donner une suite favorable
la réponse est pourtant derrière ces
murs dans les archives militaires de
l'armée au château de vincennes
tout y est consigné sous le sceau du
secret défense
mais le ministère de la défense a
systématiquement ignoré toutes nos
demandes pendant plus de trois mois
pourtant l'italie a envoyé 15 commission
rogatoire à la justice française la
plupart restés sans réponse
[Musique]
face à cette omerta systématique nous
partons en normandie à la rencontre d'un
ancien ministre de la défense hervé
morin
c'est lui qui est aux affaires quand
l'ancien président de la république
italienne accuse directement la france
ils n'avaient pas réagi à l'époque et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas l'air de s'en
souvenir ustica un avion de ligne en
1981 avion de ligne italien qui est
abattu par un avion de chasse
on sait pas
on sait pas qu'elle est l'avion de
chasse qui l'a battue et au moment où
vous étiez ministre de la défense en
2007 2008 on a le président de la
république italienne qui s'appelle
francesco cossiga qui donne une
interview télévisée
ouais je vous montre
les français qui ont fait décoller un
chasseur du porte avions clemenceau un
chasseur qui avait lancé un missile
jardon
[Applaudissements]
ouais et alors et alors il n'y a pas eu
à soir-là de réponse officielle de la
france à lutter moi j'ai toujours lever
tout ce qui m'a été demandé
donc en clair
d autres choses c'est une procédure
judiciaire en cours j'imagine que lui
serre la défense et des saisies c'était
moi ça me dirige donc ustica vous savez
c'est pas une histoire et quand le
président de la république italienne
parle à la télévision où croyez que je
suis un train de suspect raconte le père
prescillia monsieur retraité est ce
qu'il ya un juge qui a demandé à lever
le secret défense
plusieurs dizaines de commission
rogatoire et pour demander des archives
françaises etc
c'est honnêtement merci beaucoup
vraiment on dit par ici qu'ils soient en
35 ans les autorités françaises n'ont de
toute façon jamais parlé d' ustica sans
doute parce que derrière le crash du dc9
se cache une affaire d'état un projet
secret d'assassinât de kadhafi dans les
années 70 le jeune dictateur libyen
finance déjà le terrorisme grâce à ses
immenses ressources pétrolières et avec
le soutien du bloc soviétique pour
l'occident c'est un épouvantail
un calmant benneteau à cette époque
kadhafi était l'ennemi numéro 1 de
l'occident pole dance comme plus tard
saddam hussein oussama ben laden et les
états unis et la france avaient toutes
les raisons de la battre est de donner
une leçon à la liberté ou la lazio n'est
allé pêcher en 1978 kadhafi aggrave son
cas en tentant d'annexer le tchad alors
sous domination française paris à des
bases et des intérêts économiques
[Musique]
ancien magistrat antiterroriste jean
louis bruguière qui a enquêté sur la
libye se souvient à quel point paris
détester kadhafi en 1981 kadhafi c'est
l'ennemie numéro de la france il est
l'ennemi numéro 1 et l'élève n'est pas
une robe et un ennemi évident au tchad
et il est surtout un élément un pays qui
soutient donc est un point d'appui
important la stratégie que le kanak est
une stratégie qui de logique politique
de soutien résolu à l'ensemble des
mouvements d'émancipation contre
l'impérialisme occidental a cessé ses
incontestables et à partir de l'app
dénis siens à nombre d'opérations de
manipulation de groupes terroristes à
oran nous contre donc à maastricht et
d'action militaire contre la france lui
donc on est en été dans cette période si
les deux d'hypertension et le gym de
confirmation intensité où chacun où les
deux grands blocs éviter dérapages qu'il
pouvait très peut être extrêmement
dangereux pour la sécurité collective
hélas ce sont des civils comme toujours
qui ont font les frais ça a été le cas
où un dc10 d'uta
bien sûr et c'est le cas aussi pour
kazan 103 aussi je ne me sens pas
à cette époque kadhafi n'a qu'un seul
allié en europe l'italie l'ancienne
puissance coloniale qui lui achètent
beaucoup de pétrole et en échange les
italiens le laisse emprunter leur espace
aérien notamment pour aller acheter des
armes dans les pays de l'est alors
communiste
un laxisme aérien qui exaspérait au plus
haut point le patron des services
secrets français alexandre de marenches
comme nous le confirme l'ancien numéro 2
des services secrets italiens
est-ce que alexandre de marenches avait
exprimé de la colère vis-à-vis de vous à
propos de ces couloirs aériens empruntés
kadhafi alors avec moi de marange était
plus qu'affichée les têtes orages il
était furieux contre les italiens à
cause de toutes les facilités que nous
avions accordé à kadhafi
donc les français était furieux et il
vous l'ont dit clairement ce qu'ils nous
ont dit lors d'une rencontre le 9
janvier 1980 à la piscine leur quartier
général à paris les français se
plaignait de la couverture totale que
les italiens données sur leur territoire
aux agents libyens
[Musique]
l'espionnage français était donc furieux
contre kadhafi et l'italie
six ans après moustique a interviewé par
paris match
le patron des services secrets français
alexandre de marenches reconnaît qu'il
souhaitait l'élimination du leader
libyen dès 1976 j'ai conseillé aux
américains de liquider kadhafi
ils ont refusé
[Musique]
quelques mois plus tard invité sur le
plateau d' apostrophes
[Musique]
alexandre de marenches confirme que
kadhafi était bien dans le viseur de la
france vous avez un micro peut-être sur
vous donc vous avez c'est à ça c'est à
jean lartéguy dans paris match vous avez
dit qu'un jour est un jeune officiel oui
vous avez conseillé aux américains aussi
bas le meurtre de kadhafi au moment où
des bus ont commencé à la [ __ ] la
pagaille dans le monde
les américains n'ont pas voulu gg j'ai
lu avec plaisir l'arctique de secondes
lartéguy dans paris match
il parle de 76 alors nous en avons parlé
de cela nous avons examiné cette
éventualité des 70 71
mais des états unis ne se livraient plus
à ce genre d'opération parce que disait
il la seconde guerre mondiale était
terminée toujours dans paris match de
marange se vante de nombreuses
opérations secrètes contre des ennemis
politiques
nous avons réglé 30 greenpeace en onze
ans sans vagues greenpeace c'est le
dynamitage du rainbow warrior en 85 en
nouvelle zélande un mort par accident et
un immense scandale mais alors je me dis
qu'il ya problème en des accidents qui
ont réussi et à lui cette île desquels
vous alors je vais vous dire moi j'aime
bien les noms mais je vais vous dire
tout de suite on parle de ce qui avait
été plus ou moins envisagé
ouais mais jamais des autres bien sûr
mais est ce qu'ils voulaient donner dit
oui je comprends pas ce que j'aimerais
bien savoir les noms des gens qui qui
sont morts par hasard dans un accident
d'avion ou 2 1 et enfin il assume qu'il
y ait parfois eu des dommages
collatéraux
je dis et je dis encore maintenant un
peu avec ont peut-être que le service de
l'état le service de la côte de la
liberté ça vaut un certain nombre
d'accidents de parcours accident de
parcours les 80 à mort douce ti-cats de
marenches n'en dira pas plus et il
décédera en 1995
mais son ancien directeur de cabinet est
vivant michel roussin qui a été ministre
par la suite après de nombreuses
demandes d'interview il finit par nous
laisser ce message fait revenir sur un
sujet très anciens moi je ne me lance
pas dans es loin loin d'être occupation
et donc ne pas répondre d'un autre temps
trente cinq ans après la douleur des
familles italiennes restent donc sans
réponse française
les hommes politiques se taisent les
anciens agents restent secrets tout au
long de notre enquête nous avons
sollicité à de nombreuses reprises le
ministre de la défense actuel jean yves
le drian
sans réponse pour connaître la position
officielle de la france
les archives de la défense sont secrètes
pendant 60 ans jusqu'en 2040 pour
rustique à la dernière solution qui
s'ouvre à nous c'est d'aller au point
presse hebdomadaire du porte-parole
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cet avant
dernier point de presse de l'année le
porte parole
et justement un ancien journaliste qui a
été en poste en italie il a entendu
parler douce ti-cats mais il ne répondra
pas non plus mais c'est la france qui a
tiré sur l'avion italia si je vous
répondais j'improviserai je sais pas
professionnel d'accord c'est pas sérieux
officiellement malgré tout répondre à
cette question est-ce que et non parce
que je n'ai pas la réponse
et moi je n'improvise pas je suis
fortement jeunes improvisent pas donc je
vais pas dire ah ah j'ai l'impression qu
il ferait pas dire ce que je ne sais pas
ce serait malhonnête de main pas je vous
dis simplement je dis pouvoir la
question j'en suis ravi si vous
m'envoyez exactement la demande avec
qu'est ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
je me laisse à voir je vais enquête et
je vais demander en fait demandé au
service historique de la défense
j'ai pas de sujet pas de problème le
sujet pas difficulté d'accord avec vous
merci
hélas malgré ses promesses et des
relances par mail le porte parole est
ensuite resté aux abonnés absents
l'ouverture des archives secrètes
française c'est évidemment ce que
souhaiterait des familles de victimes
pour que francesco arrête de s'épuiser à
ressasser cette nuit de l'été 1981 il
faudrait une réponse claire au sommet de
l'état français
quand renzi le premier ministre
rencontre hollande en marge des
discussions il pourrait demander
écoutez il ya une histoire qui dure en
italie depuis 35 ans pouvez vous me
donner un coup de main pouvez vous me
dire si vous savez quelque chose en soi
car vous savez probablement quelque
chose sauf miracle les archives
françaises ne seront ouvertes qu'en 2040
donc francesco aura 72 ans beaucoup
parmi les familles de victimes du crash
du stick à risque de mourir sans avoir
su par qui et pourquoi
leurs proches ont été pulvérisés au
dessus de la méditerranée
un soir de juin 1900
[Musique]